check out the Olsen twins a stylish and
chic in the edits inside story this week
you're really beautiful adversity thank
you yeah the 30 year old twins look
sophisticated and get super candid in a
rare interview with the max mary-kate
finally confirmed her marriage to
Olivier Sarkozy revealing how she
balances marriage with work quote I have
a husband
two stepkids and a life I have to go
home and cook dinner her trick quote I
run on the weekend you find the thing
that helps you relax and if you don't
have it you have to look for it the
notoriously private sisters stay off
social media ashley explains why quote
we've never been connected to our fans
in that way we've stayed quite sheltered
in that sense instead the pair reaches
fans through fashion mary-kate says
quote we just want to help women feel
however they want to feel that's the
beauty of clothes et caught up with
elizabeth Olsen earlier this year she
raved about how her older sisters do it
all they've taught me about anything
everything my whole life the best tip
that they've shared with you I just
think I learned from watching that but I
wish I could do everything exactly the
way they do it but I can't pull it off
[Music]